[Música]
y llegamos directos a alemania porque
pasajeros en las terminales aéreas de
frankfurt y munich quedaron o parados
por esta huelga personal en tierra de la
aerolínea lufthansa vamos entonces a los
detalles de este paro de trabajadores o
con nuestro corresponsal en berlín tomás
sparrow tomás a los saludos qué es lo
que está pasando actualmente
la aerolínea alemana lufthansa explicó
en un comunicado a principios de semana
que deberá cancelar más de 1.000 vuelos
esta semana la mayoría de ellos hoy
miércoles en los aeropuertos de
fráncfort y de múnich se trata de casi
todo el plan de vuelos de lufthansa en
esos dos aeropuertos un plan de vuelos
cancelados que afectará según explicó la
propia lufthansa a más de 130 mil
pasajeros la razón detrás de estas
cancelaciones es la decisión del
sindicato ver.di de convocar a una
huelga que afectará principalmente al
personal en tierra que tiene el objetivo
de según explicó birdie aumentar la
presión sobre la dirigencia de lufthansa
con miras a una negociación salarial a
un aumento salarial lufthansa explicó
que había presentado una propuesta de
aumento salarial que verdi sin embargo
en un comunicado calificó de
insuficiente se espera que las próximas
discusiones en cuanto a este tema
salarial se realicen la primera semana
en la ciudad de fráncfort
tomás me pregunto qué más están pidiendo
los empleados digamos que los llevo a
esta huelga este para el día de hoy
lufthansa que es la principal aerolínea
alemana explicó que la cancelación de
estos vuelos por cuenta de la huelga
sindical del personal en tierra tendrá
un impacto operativo masivo un impacto
que será además en plena temporada alta
en época de vacaciones escolares en la
que muchas familias alemanas salen al
exterior y utilizan en particular los
aeropuertos clave de fráncfort y de
múnich o una temporada que además ha
estado marcada por el caos por demoras y
cancelaciones en varios aeropuertos de
europa y que se debe en especial a la
falta de personal en alemania se estima
que faltan unas 7000 personas unos 7000
empleados en el sector aéreo lufthansa
explicó en el caso de las cancelaciones
actuales está tratando de comunicarse
con los pasajeros afectados y está
tratando también de reubicarlos en
vuelos alternativos si bien dejó en
claro que las opciones disponibles en el
momento son bastante limitadas y que el
impacto de esta huelga puede incluso
extenderse en los próximos días con más
relaciones y más demoras